en un parque infantil en budapest estas
madres están consternadas dicen que
están angustiadas porque las personas
que interrumpen sus embarazos en hungría
deben ahora según la ley escuchar
primero los signos de vida del feto
esto es un paso atrás estamos volviendo
a los tiempos antiguos
no puedo imaginar cómo el gobierno puede
decir esto sin más es absurdo
el decreto exige a los proveedores de
atención sanitaria que muestren a las
mujeres los signos vitales del feto de
forma que se identifiquen claramente
antes de poder realizar un aborto un
requisito defendido por el gobierno de
extrema derecha de viktor orbán que se
asemeja a las llamadas leyes del latido
del corazón en varios estados de eeuu
que he traído a este bebé como
ilustraciones de un niño de 10 semanas
tiene manos piernas puede chuparse los
dedos y el corazón late lo que demuestra
que es un ser vivo
estuvo casi nada pero los ginecólogos
dicen que el término latido es
problemático porque en las primeras
etapas del embarazo aunque haya
actividad eléctrica el feto no tiene un
corazón funcional y que el sonido en
realidad es recreado por el ecógrafo
el aborto en hungría se legalizó en 1953
y se permite hasta las 12 semanas de
embarazo por motivos médicos o sociales
en el límite de 12 semanas puede
ampliarse en caso de defectos en el feto
los grupos de derechos reproductivos
temen que hungría pueda seguir los pasos
de la cercana a polonia que junto con
malta son los únicos dos países de la
unión europea donde el aborto está
totalmente prohibido